oh
it's will
all right if you could put me on speaker
i would direct you how to get in
i had my daughter said if i have to do
like a call with the family
[Music]
so
just to let you folks know when the room
thank you and just to let you know we
oh
i'd like to uh start by uh standing
pledge of allegiance representative
seaworth would you lead us in the pledge
religion
i pledge allegiance to the flag of the
thank you good morning everyone
as chairman of the labor industrial
rehabilitative services committee i find
that due to the state of emergency
declared by the governor
as a result of the covert 19 pandemic
and in accordance with house rule 67
and the governor's emergency order
number 12 pursuant to executive order
2020-04 this public body
is authorized to meet electronically
this is a public hearing on bills
referred to the committee
an executive session may follow please
know that there's no physical location
for members of the public to observe
and listen contemporaneously to this
meeting however in accordance with the
emergency order
and confirming that all members of the
committee
and select legislative staff have the
ability to communicate contemporaneously
during this meeting
through the zoom electronic meeting
platform and the public has access to
contemporaneously listen
and if necessary participate in the
meeting by zoom platform or by telephone
all necessary access information has
been made available in the house
calendar
and through the electronic calendar on
the general court website
the notice of this meeting notice
complies with house rule
rsa 91-a
anyone who has problems accessing the
meeting should call 271
3600 or email hcs
at ledge dot state dot
nh dot u s
in the event the public is unable to
access this meeting the meeting will be
adjourned and rescheduled
christine dyer is a staff member
assisting us today
please note that all votes that are
taken during the meeting shall be done
by roll call
vote and remind everyone that is uh
has their video on
off it must be on when you vote
let's start the meeting by taking a roll
call attendance
when each member states their presence
please also state
whether there is anyone in the room with
them during this meeting
which is required under the right to
know law clerk would you
call the role in time here
in l.o.b see we're here
at work people around and will be
present
callum
myself in llb nunes
good morning i am present at home alone
in pelham
warden good morning i'm in my home
office in manchester
alone
[Music]
present in the lobby pro
here at home and there are electricians
going in and out installing solar panels
home in my home office my wife is in the
uh
building with me susie
at home all alone rudy
home at my home office uh my assistant
will be coming in around 10 o'clock
[Music]
schmidt i am home in my home office in
nashua alone
to me here at the lobby
bouchard i'm here along
i'm opening the hearing on executive
session on senate bill
61 call representative huff
for a motion uh thank you mr chair
um uh to have
uh senator bill 61 uh
second i'd also like to uh motion
for the uh amendment uh the
representative
so you're moving amendment 2021-100
correct which has been presented to
the committee members does every
committee member have a copy of the
amendment
yes
okay representative hoffman
version of seaworth thank you mr
chairman i'll i'll go ahead and talk
about the amendment
um since i had it drafted and
it sounds like it's in everyone's email
this morning so hopefully you have a
chance to look at it
unfortunately it's very short especially
relative to what we've seen before
my concern here was in the section
273 d11 uh which was part of the
original build
uh it states and i'll read from the
original text the attorney general and
each county attorney
shall investigate any complaints and
violations of this chapter
and so on um my concern
was actually a couple things with this
first of all um
requiring each county attorney to
investigate
prosecute
to me it sounded like we're asking the
counties to get involved
with an area oh and thank you christina
it's up on the screen there
um asking the county attorneys
to get involved in areas of labor law
which
they may never have been before
furthermore we're requiring them to get
involved
with areas of labor law which they never
have before
and that concerned me from the 28 a
standpoint are we imposing a cost on the
counties
and if so uh aren't we required to
to pay for that but secondly and this
was an issue
that apparently was discussed in the
senate hearings although not here
it says the the state attorney general
both says the attorney general and each
county
setting up this parallel investigation a
duplicative
investigation process of any complaint
that eventually will have to be resolved
well who's actually responsible
or as the assistant attorney
general greg albert said in the senate
hearings
if it doesn't get resolved it sets up
this double jeopardy case where
the state has a prosecution and the
county has a prosecution and they're
going on at the same time
so to solve that i had this amendment
drafted which took out the
explicit reference to the county
attorneys and said the attorney general
or his her designee which allows
um a single point of contact to
designate the counties
if that's the appropriate way to do it
within the state's attorney general
office or
if it's a different department
so that's the gist of it it's only a
couple of words
changed
all right thank you thank you thank you
all bye sarah seaworth
are there any um
i would like to speak regarding the
amendments
here in the lobby see any online
thank you mr chairman um i cannot
support this amendment
um i agree with representative seaworth
that it
uh it does uh resolve the double
jeopardy um issue
that the uh is created by having two
different entities do an investigation
um however it leaves in place a
requirement that the attorney general
or designee investigate and prosecute
that creates two problems number one
it takes the prosecutor prosecutor yeah
prosecutorial
discretion away from the attorney
general's office
it should be up to them to decide if a
case warrants investigation or
prosecution rather than us to tell them
they must prosecute every case
um therefore um i will not be supporting
this
amendment representative cahill
you're recognized mr chair i'm just
wondering if
a question of the chair um is it the
practice of the committee that will
accept
some amendments from committee members
on bills but not others that are offered
that executive session
i'm thinking of the recent experience
with hb
amendments can be presented when there
is a positive motion
um
i don't recall exactly the motion that
was on the floor
when we had uh
are you sure it was 115 113
as i recall there was an itl motion
which prevented the
consideration of the amendment i just
don't think it's our normal practice to
do things that way
in labor and perhaps in the new
but that that was another day and i just
wanted to put that question out there
for
us to think about
are always in order when it's going to
i'm trying to answer his question
because i
i don't want anyone to think that there
was something that was done
on one bill and not on the other and it
was no 115
113 it's 113
[Music]
relative to payment for earned but
unused vacation time
i believe the motion was itl
so there was no ability when there's a
negative motion
so i'm quite confident but the
acceptance of the negative uh
motion without the opportunity to offer
a positive motion
therefore uh prevented the amendment
which would have improved the bill
uh greatly so that was that was my issue
i don't think that is the rule
representative
when there is a positive motion that's
always open to many
as many amendments as people want to
present with this negative motion
[Music]
um
and then the first motion was a a
negative motion
uh had the first motion been a positive
motion it would have been able to be
done
hope that answers your question whether
you don't like the answer or not i
apologize but uh
that we are trying to be consistent and
i think i have been
um so um
we have a an amendment there is a motion
on the floor there
we are in discussion mode are there any
other questions
regarding the amendment
in the llp seeing none
the um motion is
on on the amendment if you're in favor
of the amendment you will vote yes if
you are
against the amount amendment you will
vote no
call
see where it goes yes abalone
callum
carol
mackie myself votes yes nunes
nunez votes yes warden
[Music]
yes sullivan 11 votes no
susie juicy vote now
rudy ruining votes no
cahill payhill votes no
schmidt schmidt no
to me let me vote to know
who shards you can't vote for now
educate action
infant time you've been tying votes yes
amen the amendment passes
the motion on the floor is ought to pass
with
amendment representative huff are you
recognized
thank you mr chairman members of the
committee
you heard approximately six and a half
i personally received over 200 contacts
ranging from to postcards to qualcomms
it's quite clear that this bill is
opposed it's polarizing
the decisions we make today will impact
following those who contacted us
but it will shape the workforce
landscape and new hampshire
as such it is our task to unpack
what this bill does and does it do and
to make not
only the legal but the more of the
correct decision
that will best suit new hampshire it is
clear
through the testimony received by this
committee that those involved
do not want this to pass it's clear that
those involved
unions believe in the benefits the
unions provide them they would like that
to continue
it's also clear that those involved in
unions believe that this bill
would be detrimental to the union's
ability to provide
the services that they have come to
enjoy and expect
however such several questions still
remain
which may be asked many times a specific
evidence
of how this bill would prevent legions
from performing negatives and functions
that must provide anecdotal stories
although compelling are not the evidence
required to support such a position
this bill does not curtail any current
functions
except one that one's forced membership
as well as forced payment for that
membership
those who are against this bill claim
repeatedly
that they have a right to a decent age
and to provide for their families
through the membership
and the terms that fund their
negotiations as well as apprenticeships
and legal assistance this is the
fundamental issue
nothing can be a right in which you have
to steal from someone else
just because you have benefited in the
past it does not give you
the legal uh right or the morality right
to hold a gun to someone's head and
demand a force
uh you force them to pay for your
benefit as such the government cannot
take sides of the free market
this bill within the practice of
institutional coercion
and force against the workers of new
hampshire
furthermore unions and owners would be
free to negotiate the contracts
facing fit one issue that was brought up
often was how it is to benefit from
media agreements
this is at the discretion of the unions
they may decide to either have a human
represent all workers in a shop
and thus must accommodate those who do
not pages
or the unions may decide to only
represent union members
in which case there is no such
obligation
tied to non-union employees it's their
choice
in closing i believe our needs will be
stronger
our workforce will be stronger our new
hampshire advantage will be stronger
i recommend this canadian support the
motion for ought to pass with amendment
questions here in the lobby or to me
comments or regenerative attitudes
to speak after i don't specifically have
a question that's my apologies
you're recognized to speak on the
emotion oh thank you
thank you mr chairman last week in this
committee
we sat through a seven-hour hearing
where community member after community
member
begged us yet begged us not to take yet
another sledgehammer to
whatever is left of the american middle
class following two
of the most downwardly unequal economic
catastrophes in american history only 12
years apart from one another
we listen to them tell us that their
unions were there for them and despite
what glossy postcards with clearly fake
actors would have you believe
passing this legislation would be bad
and we listen to the leaders of business
and industry
the same people who loathe the unions
they deal with
as they swore up and down to us that
there is just a line of companies
waiting at the border for us to pass
this legislation
so they can set up shop here and make
life better for everyone
it was clear in this committee that
there was a struggle last week
and the only question on my mind is
which side are you on
first let me dispel the fiction that
this legislation isn't aimed squarely at
unions
when i asked a supporter of this bill in
the hearing why if this
wasn't a union busting bill why all of
the normal union busters were lining up
to support it
and he responded with saying i don't
know that it will have no
impact on private sector union
organization
and he's right it will have an impact
the bia
the afp new england taxpayers and
chambers of commerce aren't supporting
the bill
because they are committed to supporting
democracy in the workplace
they don't give one holler about that
their support is there
because this is the second part of the
plan that has been in place to bust
unions over the last four years
and it is propaganda that i myself have
fallen victim to before
part one consists of industry business
leadership and their allies
whispering into the years of every
non-union worker in america
to try to make them jealous they say
look at the unions
look at all the nice stuff they get the
nice pay
the benefits and they go on strike
despite those
you don't get any nice stuff don't you
hate the union and how entitled they are
and then they propose this alec
legislation
hoping that the same poor people they've
been spoon feeding nonsense to
won't stand up for the union and in this
case
they were wrong we had plenty of people
from across the political spectrum
including independents liberals and
former
republican reps come before us and tell
us this legislation is bad news
we had no such equivalence on other
issues
there were no democrats that came before
us to tell us
that paid sick days were a bad idea
where the minimum wage was bad
it just didn't happen i've fallen for
this industry propaganda before
and now i realize the answer isn't for
less people to have solid unions
it's for more people to have them in
fact every worker
should have access to a union whether
they're in bristol new hampshire or
bessemer alabama
the very least we can do here today is
not
go out of our way to make things worse
for the working-class people in new
hampshire who labor every day
and it is on that note that i will end
my remarks
with this uh old mine don't listen to
the bosses
don't listen to their lies us poor folks
haven't got a chance
thank you for your comment
representative to me you're right
i've got a comment as well yes okay
when the majority of a group of
employees decide
that it is in their best interest to
bargain with their employer
as a group rather than as individuals
they go through a process that
culminates in an election
being held by a government agency if a
majority
of the group votes for the union
the group is then certified as the sole
bargaining agent
this means that all negotiations for
wages
hours benefits and working conditions
between the employer
and the employees in that unit will be
held by the group's
collected leaders and or
by appointed union staff no one
in the group is ever required to join
the union
nor is anyone in the group required to
pay dues
or service fees at that time
at some point in the future generally
contract negotiations are held
proposals by both sides are made and
agreed to
such as safety and sick lead procedures
salaries and benefits or advancement by
seniority and or by merit
one such proposal that can be made by
the union
is that all members of the bargaining
unit
pay a service fee for the cost of
negotiations
and representation once
all these terms are agreed to by
management
and by a vote of the union membership
they become company policy
and as such must be adhered to by both
the employer
and the employee senate bill 61
can not be allowed to interfere with
this
mutually negotiated agreement between
two private parties
and as such uh
senate bill 61 should be voted and
expedient
legislation thank you thank you
representative tooney
to me uh representative turcotte
uh in the lobby and then followed by
members online i see your hands
representative thank you mr chairman uh
good morning everybody um
i rise in support of this uh motion
um i'm gonna give you a little bit of
background on my experience
dispel a few uh
issues that seem to always come up in
this debate
i am a 36-year union member
i have five years to go if i stay till
mandatory retirement
um 36 years i joined 36 years ago i
joined my union voluntarily
uh we are a approximately a 99 percent
voluntary union people join because
for the majority of us in my union
the issue comes down to freedom freedom
of choice
and value received i constantly
hear that this is an issue about
republican versus democrat
uh union versus anti-union that's just
not the case there are a lot of
republicans i know
a lot of republicans who are union
members i
know a lot of democrats who are union
members it's it's it's not
it's not a republican versus the
democrat
during my 36 years i spent nearly eight
of those years
in leadership positions at our national
union i was a negotiator as a board of
director i worked on many
uh committees involved in arbitrations
um i've done a lot of union work um
personal union work during my time
one of the things i found interesting
during
the hearing the other day
was one of the most common
issues or complaints or expectations is
that
should this pass there's going to be
this mass exodus
of union members from the existing
unions
now i know in my personal experience
we've never seen that happen
as i said we're about a 99 voluntary
union
so
as the hearing went on i i just randomly
asked two individuals
who i knew had been affected by the
janus decision
three years ago which extended right to
work to all public sector unions
and prior to that i've been trying to
get data on just how many people had
dropped out of union so
we had a uh a former rep who was
testifying
he's a current firefighter and i asked
him specifically
how many members of your brothers in
your firefighter unions have
a little bit a little while later uh
rich gullah from the seiu
who represents i believe he said one uh
private union and then uh one private
sector union and then
40 plus public sector unions i asked him
the same question
after janus and his answer was
none in fact we've gained membership
that uh fear grenade if you will that
all of a sudden
members are going to start leaving just
won't happen and the reason
is those union members feel
or believe that they are receiving an
adequate value from their union
just as i do i will say
however that at any time in my remaining
five years at the ili pilots association
if i believe i'm not receiving an
adequate
to stop being a union member and stop
paying
uh union dues i pay one in one and a
half percent of my
wages every year i can plan on
continuing that
i get good value and i uh should have
the ability for uh
freedom of choice should that point ever
thank you very much
thank you representative representatives
online representative cahill
is recognized thank you mr chair
for the record i am not now nor have i
ever been a member of the union i
haven't had that
opportunity though i i would have taken
up
and i i agree that there is value as my
good friend mr torkat said that there is
value in the union
and people should pay for what they get
if you don't contribute to the
to the union either by a union dues or
union fees you're simply getting a free
ride
and having all the others all your other
colleagues uh
pay for this benefit that you receive at
no cost and this just doesn't work that
way in our society so i will be voting
thank you representative burundi
followed by representative bouchard
thank you mr chairman um we sat through
seven hours of hearings uh last week
with some 1700 plus people emailing in
with their
their desires to press the vote against
this bill
um we heard a lot of testimony a lot of
good things that the union does for
people
so i'd like to ask
what this group from fairfax virginia
has ever done for anyone a lot of people
in new hampshire are born and raised
here they work here
they support their community this group
from
virginia comes up here for one reason i
think
raise money they they raise money from
our new hampshire citizens
and take it back it goes into coffers in
virginia
and new england people or whoever is
behind all this
case in point mr chairman members
i'm living in the house i grew up across
the street
was a family that had two girls
young girl that was my age we were
friends
but we they were very quiet and stayed
to themselves and so didn't we
but as we grew up and raised our own
families now i'm back here
i moved in my house to take care of my
mother
two generations later across the street
the granddaughter moved into that house
a young girl uneducated
hard-working single mother she worked
two
i was in uh hannaford's one day and
she approached me you know we had we
really never speak outside of saying
hello
she approached me and said mr burundi
i sent some money to your friends
i said my friend she goes yeah the
working people
working people that are sticking up for
your rights
i said the right to work people she goes
yes
and i i could only give them 25 because
that's all i could afford
i i was stunned i grabbed her by the
shoulders and said maria
thank you for thinking of me don't ever
send them money again
they have plenty of money and i know you
struggle to support your son
and then as i walked away with tears
going down my eyes
i felt that knife in my heart about to
stick up for these people
as long as i can and expose the people
for what they are
they have never done anything to help
people in new hampshire
they've never stopped the family from
losing their home in foreclosure
having their motor vehicle repossessed
they have never contributed morally
physically or financially to someone who
lost
a loved one these are people here
in new hampshire our union members and
our working people
are our community where this money goes
to virginia they don't do anything and
they don't care about what happens to us
here in new hampshire
we just wish they tried to stop fooling
the people of new hampshire
and tricking them into donating to
something that works against them
and our community thank you mr chairman
i would
love to take any questions that anyone
has
thank you representative burundi
you're on mute representative
thank you mr chairman and thank you
fellow
colleagues uh as a long-time
president for over 30 years
as a president of a local and a
negotiator for
over 40 years i'd like to make
uh a connection of why i cannot support
this bill i cannot support the right to
work bill
s sb 61 because i feel that this bill
is unfair to workers it will allow
employees to benefit from a collective
bargaining agreement
without contributing to the cost of
negotiating
as well as implementing the collective
bargaining agreement
i also am very concerned
with the workforce morel there will be
created by this bill
because the right to work bill sb 61
will pit workers who have contributed
to the cost of the collective bargaining
agreement against those that have reaped
the benefits
without contributing to the costs and
that's a big concern
because i can remember when i was
employed that people who were not
members
nobody spoke to them they were great
teachers
but they were ostracized until
we negotiated a
an agreement with the school board for a
a fee for them to pay for the
negotiation process
thank you thank you representative i
have hands up
on the zoom representative sullen smith
thank you mr chairman if i heard it once
i heard it a thousand times
right to work is not right for new
hampshire
new hampshire rights from all all
corners of the state
testified in opposition to this bill i
lost count of the number of republican
voters who came out forcefully against
right to work for less
our republican brothers and sisters
clearly do love their unions
of course the out-of-state lobbyists
made their case
they directed us to look carefully at
the states of have passed work to
right to work in the last few years
that was clever because right to work
does not have
an immediate impact as uh representative
turcotte
found out through his questioning this
is a long-term
if if you look more closely at these
states that have had right to work for
some decades
they're the ones who are earning less
they're the ones with weaker unions
they're the ones with more folks on
welfare it's a long-term impact on
unions and workers that are of concern
right to work is union busting
legislation plain and simple
and it's not right for new hampshire
let's not join the race to the bottom
new hampshire should be raising up and
supporting our workforce
right to work for less is wrong for new
hampshire it should be itl
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative smith
thank you mr chairman i'd like to
highlight what i took away from
testimony from last week and more in the
hundreds and hundreds of emails that we
received
this is what i heard i was able to buy a
house for my family and participate in
my community
in my church in supporting the food bank
and special olympics and the nashua
children's home
because of my union i have more
disposable income to spend
here in new hampshire in my neighborhood
and to support local businesses isn't
this what we should be striving for
secure families and strong communities
the truth is nobody is ever forced to
join the union
and this bill is an unnecessary
intrusion by the government
and that you know this will do what it
has done in other states
it will destroy good unions we've stood
against this
together for almost 40 years and we need
to do this again
thank you mr chairman thank you
representative susie
thank you mr chairman um
i know everything's been stated but i'm
going to reiterate a few things that uh
i took away from the hearing um
first of all this is going to be my 11th
time voting against
this legislation and some of the
problems i have
and i think people hit the notes very
well
opposition to this bill during
the hearing the emails uh people
testifying
to me it's very clear um that they don't
want right to work here
that it's not a problem um
what i find problematic
is as a committee
and i said this to mr juve
from the bia is that on two other bills
we clearly stated that
there wasn't they we didn't want
government intrusion
and privately held businesses
so why now why a union company
why are we going to have government
intrusion in a
privately held company answers pretty
simple
because it's a union there's no
statistical data that anybody showed
during the hearings that's
show that this is going to benefit the
new hampshire economy
there's no statistical data showing that
people are going to line up at the
borders
to come here and open new businesses
what was very clear was that
our constituents do not want right to
work here
it's disappointing to see that an ought
to pass
thank you are there any other members of
the committee
online that would like to speak on the
motion
i see no others anyone in the
lob wishing to speak
anyone wishing to speak a second time
representative
pageant thank you mr chairman i watched
a question for you
um i appreciated your earlier
uh commentary with representative cahill
about
committee consistency on making sure
we're hearing the same things
if that is the case wouldn't the correct
motion
on this be to retain
because the logic that was established
and the president that's established by
the majority of the committee on labor
as it regarded to the minimum wage bill
was that we were not going to deal with
legislation in committee
that was actively being debated in dc
which
the pro act a bill that would strip out
a lot of state's rights to work laws
is so in the name of that consistency
wouldn't that be the correct motion
so so when this when this committee
retained
the 15 hour minimum wage bill we said
that we didn't want to move forward with
it because
we were waiting to see the fate of
competing legislation in washington
that might influence state decision
if this house and it ultimately gets
signed a right to work law
and then the pro act immediately comes
afterwards that strips that legislation
out
it seems like we're establishing a
precedent for the minimum wage
i don't necessarily agree since you
asked this of me uh that there's that's
apple's apples the
the right the minimum wage was initially
pending immediately with the new cares
act
and some of the things that were going
on uh the pro
act um see is either immediately pending
or something that's going to come up
in the next week or two i believe that
was my understanding of why
i at least supported
i would like to make a comment uh if
everyone else
has completed their their comments on
the motion of the floor
um someone actually said to me
well you took money from the right to
work people
i have never taken money from the right
to work folks
i have never given money to the right to
work
folks i've never met with the people
from the right to work
uh i did have one phone conversation
with them
um so um
companies find influence spending a
hundred thousand dollars i don't know
who they
sent it to but i don't know anyone in
this committee i certainly did not
and would not take their money even if
offered
um the
uh there's a lot of things that go on in
this state
in that regards uh there's supposedly
you know you only take what you read
fifty thousand dollars worth of money
going into a house rep race in merrimack
that's from out of state
um so
i try to look at both sides
i listened to everyone what they said i
listened and wrote excuse me read every
single email i received on this and
there were a lot
i even responded to some people
requesting some additional information
the one thing that struck me that was so
disappointing in this entire process
to me was the fear and anger
that has been instilled by the people
who
contacted me that this was going to ruin
their way of life
ruin their salaries ruin their benefits
and i tried to weigh the
positive and negative things that i have
read
we're going to have increased more
infant mortality
and and the the deaths in on
workplace or more in new hampshire than
others and
i like to deal with data show me the
data show me the information
i have no issue with unions whatsoever i
don't like some of
arbitration that comes out case in point
the city of manchester recently without
having to pay a year's page or a police
officer
after he was fired for i think some
significant cause
so some things like that i don't like to
see but
overall i do not have any issue with
unions i think
actually unions probably have done some
of the best things for this
country in the 1800s and 1900s what they
did in the five-day work week and
getting benefits and
reducing child labor and everything else
um
but it all comes down to my opinion of
what is
this going to be good for new hampshire
or not and i like it in your
um mystery box
the mystery box um analogy you use just
you don't know what's inside
so what do you want so you don't know if
anything inside that message box is good
or bad
and so you have to look at what's going
to possibly happen and i think the thing
that swayed me was the recent
article by the josiah bartlett
that states adjacent
to other states that do not have right
to work
see a significant increase in both union
and non-union
employment hampshire is a very unique
state we all know that
we cannot compare new hampshire to
alabama or wisconsin or many other
states
um we have to look at how things are
here uh into states around us
and i honestly feel
that passing this will be a
benefit to jobs
in the state of new hampshire both union
and non-union
um and that's why i will be supporting
the bill
i don't it does bother me
personally as i said earlier the fear
and the anger
as well some of the inappropriate phone
calls to my home
but hey you know that's what we that's
what we can pay the big bucks for here
um to take it and to listen to folks
and i honestly feel um
this will benefit new hampshire because
of our position in new england
because of the way new hampshire is the
way our tax position is
um young people are coming back in new
hampshire
and i hope this would even help them so
i'll be supporting bill
thank you for listening i see no other
questions or comments
in the love i see no hands up
on my on the zoom board or
physically uh mr clark
the motion of the floor is ought to pass
with amendment
if you're in favor you'll be voting yay
no mr clark please call the roll
uh seaworth seaworth votes yes
abalone avelani vote yes
matthew myself yes nunes
nunez votes yes warden
warden votes yes turd car
charcot votes yes pro proud votes yes
void white vote yes
oh yes
sullivan eleven votes no susie
rudy rudy votes no
cahill a hill votes no diesel vestro
the mestral votes no schmidt
schmidt votes no to me too many votes no
bouchard you shared votes now
actually
[Music]
the bills up for any additional
amendment
of the business on this bill close
are there any other business coming
representative sullivan please let me
know
if you wouldn't mind who will be
presenting the minority reporting who
will be speaking on the house floor
i will do this we do plan to have just
one speaker in a pi
thank you also i will be contacting
uh many of you we uh it's been a long
time since we exact on
our previous bills and we have
i have to confirm who will be speaking
um
on behalf of or against any particular
bill that's coming in front of us
next week so just kind of
trying to make sure um that uh i have
all our ducks and girls so we make
paul's life
he's on the house floor and just just
for the record mr
um chair um the uh
each of the bills that are going to be
on the floor will have no more than one
uh speaker unless uh i get surprised um
but um obviously it's a
it's our benefit to move things along
next week i believe
understood thank you representatives
there any other questions of the chair
thank you we are uh in recess here in
the labor committee
um and i will let you know folks as soon
as you receive any additional
information or details
coming to us from the senate see you all
next
thursday wednesday thursday thank you
brian did you say you were writing the
minority report or you let us know
i will let you know and we'll get it to